we would now like to look at some
applications of the rocket equation in
which we have an external force plus DM
R DT where R is the mass of the rocket
at time T times the relative velocity of
the exhaust velocity was equal to M of R
DV rocket DT and now we want to consider
some special cases so our first example
will be a case when there's no external
force now this might be characteristic
of a rocket that's in far away from any
type of gravitational interaction and is
either speeding up or slowing down this
is a special case that will enable us to
understand our problem now let's
consider we'll draw a picture at time T
it's just to remind ourselves so we have
mass of the rocket it's moving with the
velocity V of R of T and we're going to
call this our plus I hat direction and
then at time T plus delta-t
we have our fuel Delta and fuel which
was equal to minus Delta and rocket
moving with the relative velocity U plus
V of R of T plus delta T and our rocket
itself is moving with the of R of T plus
delta T
so in our coordinate system we have to
remember that the exhaust speed is
relative to the rocket and we define
that to be you since its rocket is
moving forward and we've chosen plus I
hat in that direction
it's minus you I have and we can write
our vectors V R as V of R I hat so our
rocket equation in this special case
becomes DMR DT minus you I had equals M
R DB r dt i huh now in this equation
remember that it's important to recall
that M of R is a function of time and
unless we have an explicit model for how
the mass is ejected in principle we
can't solve for the time behavior but we
can look at this differential equation
in aspect in just by eliminating the
time completely by multiplying through
by DT in which case we have minus DM r u
equals M of R DV R now this is separable
and I can integrate it so I'll bring the
terms minus DM R over m are on this side
times u and that's equal to DV r on that
side now when we integrate we're going
to be integrating mass of the rocket say
at some initial time T initial to master
the rocket at some final time and over
here we're going to be integrating the
velocity from some initial time to some
final time when both these integrals are
straightforward on the left hand side we
have a natural log so we have minus u
natural log of M R T final over mr t
initial and this side we just have the
velocity difference
B of R at T final minus V R at T initial
now again you know we always check our
minus signs but recall the mass of the
rocket is decreasing so the log of a
fraction is negative so we have a
positive quantity on this side and
that's indicating that the velocity has
increased on that side and so we
conclude that the velocity of the rocket
at its final time is equal to the
velocity of the rocket at its initial
time but now here I'll keep this minus
sign in here minus natural log of M R T
final over M R T initial now in our
answer we need to know what the mass of
the rocket is at the final time so in
general this equation is still not going
to give us an explicit expression for V
at T final unless we have one special
case in which our final time is when all
the fuel has been burned and our initial
time is the rocket with all the fuel
there and then this ratio is a known
ratio and you can look at a variety of
different examples for that so there's
an example of solving the motion of a
rocket with no external forces